armé de pelle de pioches et de rateau
ces jardiniers d'un jour s'en allaient
planter les nouveaux arbres de l'hôpital
gérontologique de plaisir Grignon cette
semaine noisetier chèvrefeuille orangé
cornouillé allaiit rejoindre les 21
arbres déjà plantés l'an dernier sur le
site bâtil il y a 150 ans l'hôpital
abrite des arbres centenaires et sohait
aujourd'hui accentuer sa politique de
développement durable allié à la
circulation douce pour le bien-être des
résidents l'établissement est très
engagé dans politique de développement
durable notamment par ce bâtiment qui
est très qui est construit de façon très
écologique en bois et cetera et il y a
un groupe développement durable très
très dynamique dans l'établissement donc
qui réfléchit à toute une série
d'actions pas seulement sur la
construction mais en général sur la
récupération des des déchets et cetera
donc on a un établissement qui est très
motivé